c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose après les fêtes comment perdre du
poids je suis justement avec céline celi
vous êtes coach sportive comment on fait
pour perdre du poids après les fêtes moi
j'ai pris entre un et deux kg comme en
fait comme beaucoup de personnes vont
joueur déjà
donc moi ce que je vous conseille c'est
de reprendre une alimentation équilibrée
à base de légumes de fruits et protéines
c'est la base de huy et de boire
beaucoup d'eau et puis aussi on va
s'occuper de relancer un peu le système
métabolique
parce que là ça s'est un peu ralentie et
en faisant notamment quelques abdos bien
bien ciblé le premier exercices
d'abdominaux c'est d'être sûr déjà de
savoir bien concentrer notre attention
ici pour que ça ne bouge pas une main
sur chaque cuisse nous inspirer et en
soufflant de toutes vos forces vma
pousse dans les cuisses et les cuisses
résiste à inspirer relâcher la pression
souffle à les voir et là on est en train
de travailler le transverse le muscles
profonds qui tient toutes les viscères
si on a un travail et c'est celui ci
évoque ensuite la jambe tendue les pieds
flex voilà inspire sans bouger et
expirez remonter les épaules a inspiré
retenait la descente très bien encore
soufflé montella ont travaillé les
grands droits depuis ici jusqu'en bas
toute la distance des grandes gueules de
paul jeu sont bien des endroits une
dernière fois et redescendez à la petit
bonus
alors attention des voix déjà à
l'allongement de la nuque ne regarde pas
les omoplates resserrer les fessiers
resserrer le nombril absorbé j'ai
inspiré en soufflant serre et le ventre
et décoller une jambe et reposé en
soufflant décoller l'autre jambe sans
bouger le bassin c'est un beau bonus
nausée en soufflant des collèges jean ba
oui ça c'est pour les vrai costaud et
une dernière fois et stop
[Musique]
comment une fois je dois faire cet
exercice sans ces exercices là au
quotidien ou par semaine ce serait bien
que ça devienne une routine et qui dit
routine dit quasiment quotidiens donc il
faut faire dit
i séances de répétition de chaque
exercice que je vous ai fait faire et
idéalement 3 à 4 fois par semaine merci
beaucoup merci à vous et bonne année